good afternoon everyone and welcome to
today's episode of the Friday review of
apps today we're going to be looking at
for apps we're getting some really bad
feedback on our ends I'm going to pause
for a second while we try and figure out
the Ekka I suspect it's the output from
what looks like we're okay okay thank
you running for not it's still really
bad I am muted by the way
I'll tap it you have it oh no what are
we go very very lengthy delay there we
go all right so we're back at it thank
you for being with us so yes it is a
Friday review of apps we're gonna take a
look at four apps hopefully today and
after us in and Dan are going to sit in
and take a look at some games today
rather than Fred I've got a colleague
from the UX team jets hey guys thank you
for joining us yes EXT HD design so
hopefully we're going to have some
really useful feedback for you all
specifically looking at at you x which
is what we tend to focus on and we've
also got evil rollin dialing in from san
francisco today howdy howdy thank you
for joining us roaming and that's some
impressive facial hair or for a single
day's going ok let's let's kick off
we're going to start by having look at
an app that we hadn't i returned the
last week we're going to quite get
around to looking at it's beautiful
looked and i'm going to have a look at
it on my phone away cleanly fraktur e
reset galaxy nexus all right now we are
perfect so he can stay straight away
well as we as we open up we don't have
any notes yet so the idea behind this is
that it's an app which helps you take
notes sort of simple concept they try
and do it in a particularly attractive
way self-described beautiful notes see
me this over here perfect so right away
you can see that you've got this email
be able to see very well on the on the
video but it's it's kind of got this
faux wood background and instead of the
notes sit on top of that I know Roman
you've talked about this this effect of
trying to simulate real-life objects in
apps and before what do you feel has on
that well well first of all before i
talk i want to make sure there's no echo
coming from me everything okay we're all
going ok so i mean in general there's i
don't wanna say only two schools of
thought but i guess to two potential
schools of thought in indesign and
you know one is let's make everything
look like real live objects and have
wood in the background and real kind of
you know crumply paper effects and
things like that and the other is let's
go for a more kind of like simple you
know not want to say utilitarian but
more minimalist style and these aren't
of course the only two but if you were
to compare something like hollow versus
something like you know the design the
beautiful notes evokes they are
different and so there's you know it's
it's definitely a design decision it's
there's no saying that one is a hundred
percent correct and the other is wrong
but you know I think on Android we
generally prefer the the latter kind of
more the the minimal the more kind of
hollow style and you know we have you
know we have Android design that talks
about all the design philosophy behind
it and why it makes sense and things
like that but we at the end of the day
is I think the most important thing is
the users get it the users understand it
and is it fast and I think that the more
visual complexity you add to a nap in
general the the slower it gets the
potentially more confusing it gets and
so that's just one thing to watch out
for in general when I looked at this app
on a tablet on a phone the the big
problem wasn't so much with the visual
effects in styling the big problem with
me was the perceived latency for example
one of my pieces of feedback was when
you rotate the tablet from portrait into
landscape there's this kind of long
animation that takes place that kind of
takes me out of my contacts I don't know
if you'll see it on a phone yeah you
will so it kind of its it takes a little
too long for me I think and you know I'd
rather the developer I'd say spent more
time on ensuring that for example like
the currently selected note was still
highlighted across orientation changes
rather than having this kind of big
animation so I think in general does
nothing I guess wrong with the styling
but I think that it can add the
perceived latency add the visual
complexity that slows
down the app so that's kind of my
overall feelings yeah I felt the same
way that was the the biggest sort of
general piece of feedback i heard the
developers of this was that it seems
really slow that rotational latency is a
great example because it's probably
about five seconds from when you turn it
around so I'll show you here when you
turn it it's a two three or five six
seven it's like seven seconds before you
get from where we where you work for
exactly the same place in the UI we you
know you're ready here to tap something
not seasick we can go through and you
see the same sort of thing so and
similarly as well I found that when i
was doing this rotation it was sort of
losing state till you don't go back to
where you were so i don't know if you
sort of saw the workflow i was doing
there but i had already started to
create a new note and simply by rotating
the screen through landscape back to
portrait it's gone back to the beginning
so the big thing you want to do is you
always want to be maintaining state for
your application why where people switch
in and out of it but that's particularly
the case when you're doing rotations
there shouldn't be a difference between
yeah we're talking with virtual sugar
cause you know this state you shouldn't
have to start again from what you were
so that's a sort of key piece of
feedback is there's one more thing I
want to add around the styling so on a
tablet and I can't really show here but
the the styling I feel like is also
incomplete you know they're most of the
app has this kind of like a faux wood
effect and the the paper stacks in the
background but then there's parts of it
that are that are kind of completely
unstyled like for example so I the
core part of the experience of writing
notes and taking notes is the note view
in the note edit text box itself and
that was pretty much not really given
any love it's using the default font
which was fine but things like line
spacing things like padding things like
font size those are fundamental in any
note app and I feel like that was
something that wasn't really touched on
additionally the the icons at the right
of the screen they're using the built-in
framework icons the first problem of
that is that the framework icons that
comment
you know Android that are that I see
underscore many wonders for whatever
those aren't great to use it's better to
use the Android design the icons
available Android design but in general
those icons are also designed for hollow
so the iconography in the styling you
know those are two separate things so in
this app what I would recommend is
keeping the core shapes of the icons
like for example share should still be
you know those three circles but apply
the styling that fits in with your app
you know it's it feels kind of two
disparate those two separate kind of
styles between the app and those icon so
it's another point of view that's it
that's a good point so we've got the app
up on it on a tablet here at the moment
so this is where you're referring to
here obviously you can see the icons on
the on the side here yes you say look
good but you know shouldn't be exactly
the same ones and it was this the bit
what you talked about which we needed
more wealth so the the actual text
editor for each night yeah exactly so if
you if you have multiple lines of text
here you'll notice that there's I think
it's like a 1 point 0 or 1 point 1 or
something line spacing so I mean if you
have like a really long line it starts
rapping it just doesn't it feels a bit I
don't want to say unprofessional but it
feels like more love should have been
given here clearly you know the design
team for this app put a lot of effort
into you know kind of the the chrome
around this this fundamental kind of
centerpiece but I think that more love
should be given to the actual
note-taking experience yeah that's a
that's a fair call yeah good comment the
other thing that I noticed as well if we
switch back to the phone I'm not sure if
you'll be able to see this very well but
the the icons here we up to the icons
that you've got for creating a new note
search these sorts of things all down
here are actually quite low res so they
look they look bad on this hdpi screen
if you compare that the tablet the
tablet actually has the right higher res
icon so they are they are visible so
down here so they do exist so this might
just be a simple case of putting the the
right icons into the right folders
so that you know all the places get the
right I phones but they definitely look
grainy here also the I've made a note
here that the the action bar appears
inconsistent so I'm not entirely sure
what I meant by that so that that looks
fine let's see but I guess it's little
things like what I would expect to see
on this screen is is a way to get back
to the previous screen and they manual
to the home screen something like that
and I don't have anything on the action
bar to help me do that pretty sure if I
hit back no back exits um so that's
that's a little bit confusing so I don't
know how to get from sort of a new note
that I've just edited back to the to the
main screen it's not entirely clear I
think what I'm supposedly is here so you
look in that fragment transaction
they're missing an ad two backs that
call and not updating the action bar
according you look so high yeah I think
I need to save an iso on posner and
sending it to email nice yeah so I think
in some cases it will work but than in
others it doesn't that's definitely
confusing you want the action but I have
a nice consistent work boy so that you
always know how to go from where you are
at the moment back to back to the main
menu or at least to somewhere where you
can navigate to other places search fair
enough some of these electrons as well
have the the problem of it it not being
clear exactly what they mean I don't
know what this tick box does yeah it's
linked so some of those icons are cab
like almost like reading buttons and
some are actions so yes it's not quite
clear what they do the other thing I
should mention yours um you know I guess
for the first time in android 4.2 saw
this kind of tool tip behavior so when
you long press on an action in the
action bar you get a quick toast like
tooltip that indicates what it is um
it's totally fine to use that for for
these types of buttons where the
iconography isn't perfect and in general
obviously you know improve iconography
test iconography on on people from
different demographics to make sure that
it makes sense to them yeah
absolutely yes I mean I think the
biggest overall tourism I had were 21
was that the navigation is confusing
it's hard to figure out where you are
what actions you should take to get
things to happen for all the great UI
chrome it's actually quite difficult to
see well it's not of you i should say
it's really slow it's slow it's it's
laggy it's sort of you're interrupting
the flow of trying to just create you
know to have this experience create
simple notes it's all being slowed down
by the UI so i think there will be my
main so the feedback is to make it
faster even if that means cutting away
from from some of the fancy chrome just
to make it faster easier to use
experience and try you know create a
navigation structure that's really easy
to understand i think one of the things
that are noticed creates tension which
has to do with you know that the general
sliding we have this billion clicked
here on the search dialog and you get a
system dialogue that matches the knoll
shape of warm is the generals diving off
the app it creates this visual attention
that you know make sure you think am I
even still in the same task still doing
the same thing yeah it feels like it's
an interruption like I've done something
wrong because I get the system dialogue
and in fact there's something like
search a better approach would be to
Jesus surgery I'll put that into your
action bar yeah so then you can you can
effectively do that so rather than
having this search you would end up with
a search view which would come along on
the top so yeah that's that's probably a
good idea where to try and make it more
of a cohesive experience okay all right
let's move on I haven't I haven't spent
as much time this week looking at all
the apt ahead of times this is going to
be a bit of a learning experience for us
as well as we go through this but let's
have a look at G apps launcher so let's
see if I download this and an open it up
first thing I get is this a big screen
of text which I believe tells me what
the app is and how I'm supposed to use
it so gf's launcher is in fact a widget
at home screen widget and this is the
the way that they've gone
to try and explain what it is and how it
works so it says an interesting approach
you know putting it all you know having
a partially it's not even a full screen
activity pop up when you hit the launch
and tell you to install the widget it's
not necessarily a bad approach though I
would probably not have gone a partial
activity oh it just may be made an
activity but I don't know if they're any
guidance around that is that just a
personal opinion thing what do you guys
think um oh sorry yawns I should mention
it's kind of hard to curiously you may
want to put the mic a little closer team
okay yeah I would opt for for a full
screen activity here for configuration
interfaces that usually seems to work
best actually from here and it might
also be a good idea to know that's
technically possible to guide users
directly to the place where widgets
actually start and the all apps folder
because I noticed that the text is
actually a little bit incorrect at least
for as far as I CSS concerned I get the
wrong instruction yeah you can really
say a long press on the home screen home
panels anymore in order to access
widgets so that might be something you
won't fix yeah so and that's something
to consider as well I mean you can just
go as simple as just changing the text
for different versions or perhaps you
know it's a slightly riskier approach
but assuming that people who have
downloaded it know how to install
widgets for their phone and sort of just
say this is a widget this is how you go
and install it rather than sort of
trying to give the detailed instructions
for someone who perhaps this is the
first time you've installed the widget
if so it seems less like whether they
would have installed your app to begin
with also if you are going to be
providing this information so you've
kind of got an about at the top and then
the installation instructions and then
you know people you want to say thank
you to it's perfectly appropriate to say
thanks to everyone but what means is
that you've actually now even on this
high-density screen you've got
scrollable text I looked at this and my
eyes glazed over Buddha terms of service
thing you just want to know how to get
started so I try and make this as
concise as possible even if it's just
this is a widget this is what it does
you know please go to the to the app
launcher or long press on the home
screen to install and kind of let it
that so we'll close that off now so I've
let's see we might follow those
instructions we'll go widgets will add
one to the home screen now so here we
are gf's launcher I'll store to buy to
drop that on the home screen so that
opens up a configuration activity which
is the right way of doing this I believe
it's going to show us a preview of what
it's going to look like along the top
and then down here it's providing us
with all the difference I guess Google
applications which you can have and
decide whether it opens the app or a web
page and which ones displays it can use
to that you can see that they're the
real-time preview is updating to show us
the different apps which it's providing
so I guess this is going to provide us
shortcuts to everything from home screen
just Andy now I would say that the
workflow here is a little bit confused
so you've got the preview at the top
then you've got an options button so
transparent is going to decide whether
it has a background and we put it on the
home screen and then save and cancel to
I guess either bought creating the
widget or to create a widget and then
underneath you've got the configuration
to select which ones they are now from a
work perspective it's kind of back to
front upside down and you know you're
kind of starting at the bottom and then
going back up into the middle and
referring to the top so it all kind of
seems a little bit confused to me yeah
3x perspective what would you say would
be the right order and put the stuff
together um I would say that the safe
cancel probably should be at the bottom
on the fixed borrow so that it doesn't
scroll hours because you have a
relatively lengthy configuration
a number of apps in here that can that
you can configure under on to the panel
so probably at the bottom makes sense if
you have a regular action bar at the top
here you might as well also use save
cancel in the action button to do that
in a couple of places so for example if
you create a new contact you can observe
that you know accepting you contact or
cancelling all of it is accessible to
the action bar so that's another space
efficient and consistent place of
displaying that functionality yeah that
seems very soon I mean you know you're
actually using up any extra space right
effective including the actions bhavin
you're gaining space and if you are
putting on underneath it's just lived
the other thing I'll point out as well
it's like it's really nice styling but
we're not using holo styling here which
is unfortunate it would be nice to see
this its menu button go away it's got an
about which I guess brings up the same
thing at the beginning you know that
would be better as an action bar item if
you're going to have it in there but you
definitely don't want the the menu
button of shame as we like to call and
if you had all this holo theme and these
buttons would look a lot nicer as well
and we just sort of feel like a one
native sort of application okay so it's
it's safe and it's going to create our
home screen widget but the other thing I
wanted to mention one missed opportunity
may be here is in the configuration
interface to do the users and
opportunity to shuffle the the icons
around so that then an order that they
prefer that doesn't seem to be possible
yeah you're right I think that there is
a way unless it's defined by the order
in which you add them I don't think so i
think it's just a simple to say yeah
that would be really nice to be able to
change the order of the items we got in
there because when i put this together I
you know activated some then deactivated
them and that's seemed to determine the
order as you said but it's nice you know
once you're done then to do a final task
know how exactly should look like very
cool okay so perfect so now we have the
widget so we're going to go back to the
home screen here and you can see how
it's all
laid out now the first thing that I
would comment on so this obviously is
for google apps if you were doing
something similar for any other company
I'd be really cautious about using
people's trade box so you've got logos
and icons which in this case are all
Google properties yeah I'm not sure
whether that breaks any terms of service
but I definitely be you know I'd be
reluctant about about doing that sort of
thing so it'd be very careful before you
using sort of names and logos of things
which belong to other companies
generally speaking it's poor practice to
do anything in google play or anything
like this where you're relying a lot of
people's brains to sort of promote your
product obviously in this case you're
doing so to make it easier for people to
get access to these which which seems
reasonable enough but yet just a word of
caution I think whenever using someone
else's brads terms of the layouts
themselves so I've got to to age of tier
1 to x 2 which has which is one we just
configured with a background at the one
underneath which is sort of a smaller
one by one without the background they
look nice recently well laid out there's
a bit of overlap in the other two by two
some of the icon seem a little bit close
together that's what I was thinking that
they're a little bit tightly packed and
I think this this app would be a good
opportunity of actually having the
sizeable widgets as well absolutely that
you can space the widgets a little bit
better and adjust them you know to the
size of your home screen as you look at
it in the context of your home screen
hmm yeah definitely I mean this is a
like ancestry perfect example to be able
to do the the resourceful home screen
widget so that they just whip it up in
theoretically then you could add more
things to it too yeah as it expands and
gets bigger there's a little
configuration icon you can maybe just
make out which is impossible to touch
right yes yeah so once you touch that
you get back in and you can configure
but it's really hard to touch that so
I'd consider trying to make that a more
easily touchable touch target you know
each other it's a direct effect of how
we packed everything is so if you space
it a little bit more evenly than you
also have a little bit more more if the
is a developer for 50 laps launcher
online learning chance ok just saw that
should i check before you i'm going on
but yeah so that's I think that's the
main point of feedback add some some
suggestions as well you got some
comments perfect yeah and they're very
quick but they very much fall in line
with what you guys are saying but just
here's kind of a good idea of how this
can work in an Android through point O
in later world basically you have just
one widget right you don't have the 2 x
24 x 12 x 1 whatever you just have one
widget and in the configuration you
specify what size it is how many rows of
icons how many columns of icons it is
and then basically it fits that kind of
nested linear layout or whatever into
whatever size the user determines so you
could potentially have a four by four in
a five by five or two by two and a four
by four whatever you want right and
basically once you specify in that setup
wizard that configuration stuff how many
rows and columns of icons you want you
can then you should then be able to drag
and drop from kind of a list of items at
the bottom right into the cell that you
want and then right now it has things
like application web page so you can
have like Google Search application
google search web page those should
really just be two separate icons that
you can drag in there so you can drag in
the Google Search application into one
of the cells and then the google google
search google com applicate or web page
into one of the cells so it becomes kind
of much easier and much simpler I think
that interface would be a little more
interactive a little more easy to
maintain easy to manage and just a
little more intuitive cool nice yeah I
think that's some great feedback so
we'll definitely hopefully the the
creator of the app is watching and you
can sort of take some of that into
account and we'll try and share share
this with you athletes as well but um
generally it's a nice idea
alright let's have a look so we've got
the developer we got Michael from them
how do you pronounce the the app it's
etao keyboard what do you call it Oh
Michael you're muted Hey well guess what
your wife um okay cool so let's let's
try set it up so I'm just going to I'm
going to grab the phone and and see if I
can figure out how it goes have you have
you already installed it all right yes i
have i put around with it have a bunch
of comments but i do want to make sure
Michael or recall is able to speak in
these not muted let's give it a test of
some Capo's and michael says he's got
some computer program but uh hopefully
hopefully he'll be able to to comment
yes I do have it installed I can go
through a some feedback on my end if you
guys would like yeah hey he just he just
left uh we're gonna try and get back in
okay let's let's a true do the other
half is well before or yeah let's do
that let's um let's let's try any day
while we're waiting this long to get
that gun let's have a look yeah any day
alright so let's have a look at it on
the hair will be back like everyone's
disappearing oh look Romans gone buddies
mustaches they left behind too neat
trick okay so this is this is any do
let's have a look so right away as we as
we started up we can see that they've
done some some custom stuff here so it's
a custom font custom sort of dialogue
come up very very very long terms of
service very very long terms of service
so the first thing I would say is that's
a really long terms of service for the
terms of privacy it's good to have a
privacy policy you can actually put your
privacy policy in Google Play that's an
option which might be able to save some
of you know some of the text you have
here by putting it on onto google play
directly for developers to be able to
look at in any case we've kind of got it
some customized dialogue even down to
the
just fine except now personally I think
something like this you'd be better off
using sort of the standard system
dialogue but greater I think we're going
to find it the only why is quite custom
it in terms of the buttons general the
buttons it seems they're the triple
coded right now it's a very location
coded they're color-coded size coded and
it seems a little bit over the top a
little bit if you follow platform
conventions have the affirmative action
on the right distance of action on the
left so that location coding should
actually be sufficient say thank be
another color is a bit much process
bigger plus it simple exactly Russia
difficult that's quadruple electrical
code em oh yeah people definitely get it
that do except is what you want them to
do but I'd say there's probably two
alternatives you can either just have
just accept like if it's that important
that's really the only thing that you
want you have accepted the back button
is a business or implied can as well so
that's one approach or at the very least
you know if you do want to make sure
that they are both there and available
just make them decline and except
respectively without so it's it's a
symmetrical and that's bothering me like
it it will too long yes it's able to
comment as well as the different font
sizes from weeds make it very look very
on them exactly and for an app which I
suspect is going to look like the UI I
think it's going to be a big part of
this you want to avoid anything which
throws that balance off so it's
exception and then hopefully the
hopefully having to sign my life away
okay so it looks fairly straightforward
in terms of I've got an empty screen
it's got today and up the top it says I
want to so let's let's type something in
want to go home ok cool so outside of
typing it's coming up with a whole bunch
of auto suggests which look like they
might be scrollable but art I suspect if
I pull the keyboard away then they will
be no okay all right so that that's
quite neat so right here I can click on
this and autocomplete for me
at this point it's not entirely clear
how I how I add this to my to my list I
guess its got share remind and answer by
press add it adds it to the list which
is quite nice again this is all very
custom bold so there was a I don't
nobody saw it on the screen but there
was a neat little sort of drop-down
animation as it as it went into place
and it's also added a bunch of other
ones if I click on it then it gives me
again a bunch of options here priority
folder or minor so I guess these are
actions that I can take on that
particular note so i see so priority is
a toggle so it's high priority or
library I guess folder lets me move into
a folder so again we've got its custom
dialogue fragment hopefully which lets
us choose which fold we want to put it
in so i'm not sure about this and so you
can create new folder or cancel so again
the council is almost redundant because
you can hit back to get out of that i
kind of don't like that choosing
something straight away like I feel like
I want to be able to accept it's not how
I choose a folder okay rather than
choosing a full boat implicitly being
the action boat could be personal taste
otherwise it seems pretty strip pretty
simple I think it not done an action bar
that seems like a conscious choice to
just have that sort of action as one
thing at the top that's certainly an
approach we have the lips have the menu
button of shame down the bottom which
does do something so this is interesting
so if i press the menu button it's it's
actually changing my UI please please
don't it's my feedback there this is
definitely not what I would expect at
charisma straight away those are the
wondering what that looks like on the
tablet I didn't have a chance I'll take
a look on the tab let's have a look on
the tablet and see what it does that
oops all right right I'm screen any day
that's figure the tablet here alright
sir any button does exactly
so this is it's kind of confusing on a
number of levels as you can see here
we've got sort of these two pseudo menu
items which have come up on the bottom
where you would expect you to on a
legacy app and you've got a bunch of
other settings so how to sort sort by
date for the priority yeah definitely
definitely not the way that I would
expect this to be laid out particularly
because yes it's toggleable so if I hit
the menu button again the menu goes away
again kind of unexpected menu button
isn't a total it's it's something I
shoot bring up the menu and ice cream
sandwich you should bring up an overflow
menu this shouldn't be there actually
part of the action bar yeah do you have
Jeff some specific feedback around that
track you yes yeah it's bothering me but
finally difficult to put into words well
I mean definitely the the menu is if you
have that legacy mentoring first of all
you shouldn't have the legacy menu but
you know on older devices you know if
you look at an excess that menu button
uh it should not do that it should
should do if it does something than it
should show the standard kind of four
pack six pack options menu but in
general I mean like like you mentioned
on android 2.1 later you simply
shouldn't have that menu there and what
that many does now is it really shows
kind of a konica settings screen but
there's also which is confusing there's
another setting screen if you press more
so there's kind of two levels of
settings so what I would probably do is
this initial setting screen I would bake
in the individual pieces like the
sorting I think the sorting and there's
there's one other thing in there um one
second this morning those actions I
baked those into the like something like
an action bar um you know for sorting
you can have like a UI like a widget on
screen that lets you you know like has
like a little drop-down that that's a
date folder priority for clear sink and
done I guess clearer and clearer is a an
action done is navigational so you may
want to have that somewhere in the top
left of the screen
or like as I gotta drop down to see what
view you're looking at what like view of
notes you're looking at but then once
you get into things like feedback and
more those are clearly you know action
bar items or you know if you have
something like an action overflow then
you press that and you see those and
then settings also should be in that
action overflow yeah absolutely mr.
settings in particular like again this
has all been customized and obviously
they've gone to some Sun lengthier to
make sure that the entire app is got a
really custom looking for you anything
on that I don't know it looks nice I
think that's a good thing but with
things like dialogues and things like
settings you know there's a certain
expectation from users that it will work
in a way to definitely with and so it's
you really have to think long and hard
about whether or not there's any value
in creating your own custom settings
which is just going to be confusing for
people so for things like sound there is
a way that you would expect that to come
up and in fact if you've used the system
the system menu here for that so if I go
back and show that again sound I click
on that it brings up the other
notification picker so now all of a
sudden even though everything else is
customized we're now back into a system
of dialogue so the system dialogue is
the right thing to display here it's
absolutely the right way to choose the
notification sound but rather than
making at the very last thing you see
this whole settings menu should already
be using that that standard systems
settings option people will understand
how it look for how it all works because
also good good place for for mentioning
how you can sort of rain in overly long
lines in your landscape tablet use if
you look at my gmail for example we are
doing what because what we call centre
drawing so we sort of compress the
dialogue of the form horizontally a bit
in order to make everything more
proportional and correctly weighted so
usually we have a left and the right
cutter that looks like a piece of paper
on grey background yes once again one
mention i just want to mention really
quickly
at beautiful notes which is an app that
we looked at before their settings were
we're not themed and I actually really
appreciated that because settings is
kind of like one of these holy places in
a nap you know there are things like
settings notifications Launcher icons
throughout the system that really should
almost beyond just feel the same they
should really look in feel kind of very
consistent and so beautiful notes did
that did a good job of that and I think
this app can can take a page out of your
book absolutely I mean I think that's
it's a temptation you know I was a UI
engineer in a previous life and there's
a big temptation once you start building
custom things to make everything custom
it's like why stop here we can make our
own scroll bars we can make our own
everything you know I get that I
definitely appreciate the feeling of
like well you know we want to make it
all consistent but as Roman says there
is there is a place to draw the line and
it's where there is something which is
always consistent between arts dialogue
settings even the action bar and and and
menus like all of these things are
pretty much consistent across that even
even some of the google apps which could
be quite different in terms of their UI
the sort of key elements should at least
be consistent across everything so you
know that if you press something on the
top right that looks like it should
bring down an overflow menu it does and
it looks the same and it's got a
settings on button and you bring that up
and it brings up that same settings view
that you used to for everything else
helps users to be in a you know to feel
at home in a structured and recognizable
environment so that they know well those
are actions and this is the overflow and
this is the navigation bar so it really
helps you in the long run you know Rep
could use those recognizable elements
from other apps and your ad as well
exactly so you do take advantage of
those things which are consistent across
like every app don't try and recreate
the wheel in those instances as
remembers this beautiful notice a great
example because it's it has a very
custom UI looks nice but certain things
are consistent are the same so that's
that
perks that I think looks really really
well relieve them give a give a shout
out here for me holding the camera and
you sure to be for real quick for the
the actual sentence completion yes works
really really really well I was really
impressed with that cool stuff yeah I
mean not that I think it's kind of a
killer feature this is the booth
multi-level onion thank you that don't
have a bang better little issue with
that actually I think on on my phone
here it's not actually showing text for
this person's icon use the bug but it
might just be some sort of like um I
don't know some sort of bug but I'm
interesting but yes that that's really
nice and in fact I'm all of this this
whole app like that's the killer feature
is the fact that it so you can save your
time so when you're trying to take a
quick note down it's going to guess what
it is you want to say I'd be really
interested to know if it if it learns
based on what you're entering in or what
other people are vented in it does bring
up the question of what was happening to
stuff what I'm typing which is probably
a good reason to read that really long
privacy policy in terms of service of
the beginning so that might be an
interesting thing to check out but yeah
so overall it also the whole app had
again like beautiful notes and it seems
to be pretty consistent around apps
which do a lot of customization it's a
little slow it's a little laggy there's
a lot of nice little animations which
look nice but they seem to slow the
whole system down so again I'd be you
know I was going to focus on something
it would be on trying to make the whole
thing more responsive less janky so it's
smoother and that can be is as important
if not more important than the overall
look and feel it's how smooth and how
quickly it operates and what makes I
think so their basic one last point so
run action bars I'm just looking at this
app and I'm trying to think like what
would it take for like how hard would it
be to just add an action bar I think
basically I mean that that microphone
button that microphone button can
probably just go into the text
box I don't like what we do with search
view and you know in the top left you
could probably have that icon right but
just purely from styling the action bar
doesn't have to look like a separate bar
right you can set the background to
something like transparent you can set
the the windows content overlay which is
the shadow underneath the action bar to
know and so the action bar basically
becomes kind of this floating thing and
so it can take on the same appearance
basically as what you see here but but
kind of feel more correct navigation and
interaction Lee and then you
automatically get that action overflow
on the top right so I think that you
know it wouldn't require too much extra
work to to make this an actual action
bar but you know just in case you don't
do that for sure make sure the top left
is reserved for things like navigation
and top right for actions and that
overflow so that's the last point I want
to make them an actual bullet cool
alright so we've got very little time
remaining but seeing is we have Michael
here I do i do want to take a look at
the at the keyboard do you actually have
it when yours excellent what's dropping
from fact I'll do you a favor see if we
can move our camera set up a little bit
closer to you as well ice all right move
it this way so that we're not blocking
the camera okay so you want to tell us a
little bit about the about the the
keyboard what's the thinking behind it
what does it do that that a conventional
keyboard doesn't Michael Young muted at
the moment you're not you did yes is
that were you saying it's just not
working that's the shame if you like
even because we're actually just coming
up to the end of our time would you
prefer we can we can hold this off and
do it first next week and give you a
chance to to get a working mic yeah that
works for you cool alright I think that
makes sense because we're a quarter to
which which is usually a cut-off time so
I guess with that thanks for thanks for
joining us Michael this week we'll
definitely look at your keyboard first
thing next week thanks to everyone who's
watching which one
worked analytics I'm not sure how well
that's working so if you are watching
you want to give us a +1 on either the
YouTube stream or on on DG posturing
that will be fantastic Thank You
professor omen for joining us this week
from San Francisco I thank you for
coming on board as well great stuff
everyone else we do this every friday at
a1 p.m. we have a moderator page where
we take nominations from app developers
who would like to have their apps
reviewed by us so please do go ahead and
add your apps in there and we will go
through and pick the top four or five
voted ones each week and check them out
for you do hang around we've got Fred
and Ian I'm going to be with us in about
15 minutes doing pretty much the same
thing but with a little more for a
little more beer and looking at games so
definitely hang around and check that
out otherwise junior next week and we'll
see you there